if you mention the submarine trial as we
call it here everyone will know what
it's about
kim was naturally inclined for
journalism the stories she sought out
were not mainstream
first thought i had in my head was what
do you mean she's missing
she was just doing her job
then she ran into a psychopath
peter madsen is a very well-known figure
he's thought of like an elon musk he's a
major innovator
kim went on the submarine with peter
matson to interview him submarine goes
down
[Music]
one person comes back
where's the other person
she was taken from the world by an act
of violence
he killed her because he could
this court case was a circus there was
some critique of the way it was being
covered by media this victim-blaming
notion what did the woman do to bring
this upon herself what did she wear why
did she put herself in that position i
wouldn't have thought twice to go on
that submarine because it was the job
that she was gonna do
she followed the book in every sense of
the word
it is the most terrifying case i ever
engaged myself in how on earth did you
think you would be able to get away with
this
it's impossible to imagine that
something like that could happen to
someone like her we can all identify
with this young woman who
just wanted to do her job
[Music]
you